instead of what's the first one this is
more stressful than all my meetings
today she's the best
okay okay this is the hardest thing I've
done today last ones a height is good to
mark
the next the last one we're doing some
sport night dances
[Music]
Hayden's got his PA day and the deal was
he joins me for the day of meetings and
then after it he would teach me some
fortnight dancing on camera so over to
you professor Hayden okay we're gonna
start with a dance move called best mate
best mates okay it's a very easy dance
no right that you did totally wrong okay
let's go here we go bring it so put your
arms up like you're a robot and you're
just swinging your arms huh but then put
your legs up like you're running uh-huh
and that's how you do fascinate it's
very easy one down boom
next we're gonna be yeah okay so we're
gonna move on to a dance move called
right so swing your arm both of your
arms up one way like her that's her ass
already here this is how you wrestle
somebody flagrant in boxing yeah okay
the swinging of the other way but like
make it you just like this yeah like
that okay then
cross your arms uh-huh cut out what
kinda yeah that's yours
uh-huh okay so you going left right left
right and then cross cross cross
uncross yeah when you do the cross
uh-huh
you have to move your legs like this you
have to move your legs this yeah like
that same I'm doing this same when
you're doing now we're getting now we're
getting complicated okay
so you have to move up you move in the
direction of the arms are against the
arms so like we're going like this yeah
you're the directions yeah and then
switch yeah okay okay ready 3 2 1 go
Oh oh you're going fast on this yeah
you're supposed to but you doing like a
double tap here boom boom like that wine
go I'm going to slow in this yeah you
are rush boom now I get it move it's not
that hard actually okay gonna move on to
your favorite my favorite was that your
favorite is a rock out lock out that
showed you this one
so first pretend like you have a giant
guitar in your hands you cry yeah then
like okay yes wait playing it it doesn't
matter what way you go okay you're a
left-handed guitars okay hmm okay and
then you go down oh yeah okay then you
lift it up and you go and shake your
hands around am i holding a guitar up
here yeah but you're like shaking it
shaking the get back in your hands okay
yeah so it goes like this
oh you got you go you go this and then
down and then up
no I just did I just made that up all
right chemical creativity mm-hm
I'm gonna do that it we're not gonna do
that you pick near the choreographer I'm
just following yeah sure okay down up
yeah
shoot the head say yay yeah all right
thanks to one of my favorite your
favorite okay one is one of your
favorites okay
it's called the flaw the floss okay yeah
so first your hip has to be the opposite
way of your hands so make your hands
into a fist yes
and then when you swing your hip comes
out you swing if it comes out yeah like
that you go back uh-huh then you switch
your hands to the other side but your
hip still swings yeah then you go there
you go yeah okay then you go in I'm
ready oh okay take that out you go back
oh my gosh you could just do it as much
time we're here oh very good
swish yeah oh but I'm still in here oh
when the arm switch the weights will
just do yeah okay okay Kenny over here
in out switch in out switch see a switch
in a switch in switch you're doing this
instead of well what's the first one
okay okay
this no no you're doing this
uh-huh you supposed to stand forward oh
the hand goes but the okay okay okay and
this yeah three two one go
this does this you do think think think
good yeah that was a little tricky for
you so I'm gonna make it a little bit
easier okay this one's a library what do
we got mr. oh it's literally just you're
making it rain money it's like this yeah
called make it rain okay that is easy so
now I'm gonna do hmm last ones a height
is good to mark hey Eddie the next
device I'll teach you how to do a dance
club dance new dance moves okay so clap
your hands then put your hands down no
out like this spread your fingers out
like you're shaking like you're not
yeah like that mm-hmm and then clap and
you put your weight on the hip no you
don't swing oh that's it straight yeah
like that yes so do you know how to fake
walk a snake walk yeah show me I do know
how to run on the spot
yeah like that except you're walking
you're bad yeah like that like that
okay okay I'm getting there what's right
you do this yeah okay first of all let
me show you how to do it
okay I wasn't doing it no you're doing
it correctly I just show you how to do
it first five-o with the hands oh my
gosh just a lot okay okay okay so the
clap has doesn't have the footwork yet
boom then you start and your hands go in
and out of every performer huh okay
footwork and then in and out like this
yeah and then class oh you still going
with you class so good good did it and
then you go that did it one more time
huh
put what is now your keep walking okay
and then you stop and do this yeah
blower doesn't what's this one called
dance-off
okay then suppose has a lot of dancing
history well I think this is tricky wait
till you oh my gosh okay okay okay
very slowly slowly boom dan7 that boom
that don't that don't i stopped and then
and then this is more stressful than all
my meetings today the best okay okay
this is the hardest thing I've done
today you ready wait till funk don't
bump bump don't bump with us no that's
great yeah okay
hey last one hardest one I'm ready
electro shuffle electro shuffle okay I
felt like this is kind of like a chevron
I'll show you how to do electroshock
okay here we go okay did you teach me go
first
cross your legs but yeah single middle
behind yep the whole time not the whole
time oh okay so you do that huh you
think your hand on top of your head
slowly swipe down like this yeah I'll
just straight done blah blah blah
while we're jumping I just like to do it
that way yeah like that like that okay
we're done
pretend like you're holding a shield
just like this
hold the sword uh-huh then go like this
this this this and then this again right
yeah yeah yeah I am left yeah right left
only three yeah so we're here left right
left
yeah like that huh but do the crisscross
what like this
Yeah right 3 2 1 go
already Chris wife can okay yeah okay
then you put your arms up arms up and
jump which way to the right way to the
right
jump oh I don't want to jump left I want
to jump this way no I know I know
then you go then you do the Chris fest
again with the white with the one to
your left
uh-huh and put your arms like this
uh-huh like this uh-huh
and then turn around oh my gosh okay and
they'll be arms drop no okay
put your arms like stop Criss crossing
uh-huh put your arms like this uh-huh
out uh-huh put your arms like this like
you'd like you're meditating or
something yeah so let's start over
oh my gosh Chris Chris guys criss cross
left
what is this you do you weren't doing
this why are you doing this like that
but you have to keep your leg out like
this out in out back and then switch
while you're doing this yeah I guess
oh my gosh don't figure so much in out
back out in back with the step already
criss cross with the wife no I know I
know I turn the other way
what do we know what's this part that's
my
distant back forward is more this is the
last fight go to ending pose okay then
put your foot over uh-huh and put your
other hand this way like you're about to
snap huh
like that okay that's your name pause
that's it thirty-one girl really put
your hands on your side
yeah it is yeah that's it do what mr. oh
how do I do
give me a score out of ten ten as one
being the worst and 10 being the best
right uh all right okay that's pretty
good
I'll take an eighth I'll take an eighth
good job I'll take an eighth I've got to
get better at it I'm gonna get better at
it
boom boom boom punch punch this time
around
oh it worked
oh good eye mr. it's good job if you
want to see some more evident hate and
fun check out the video we made on how
to make the aluminum magic ball that
ended up being a massive fail the link
is right next to me continue to believe
and I'll see you there
you need to keep hammering away until
it's perfect